it sounds like the people who were armed
were the people who shouldn't have been
and the people who should have been
weren't armed yeah the coaches but now
with certain districts or coaches could
go get from what happened a coach can
now go and go through this Guardian
program and uh be able to carry on
campus but it's foreign not all can't
you know it depends on the county you
know if you live in a conservative
County like I'm going to uh in January
the superintendent's going to be
carrying an AR pistol
you know that's up in Bradford County
where I'm doing some things with law
enforcement so I I hear a lot from these
uh Democrat establishment gun control
types they think that it's nightmarish
this idea that teachers would be armed
that we would have special law
enforcement armed in these schools but
the crazy thing is if you go back in
time they had gun clubs at high schools
clubs Red Rifle clubs people had people
had guns people were armed and then we
slowly started Banning them now the idea
of just going back to the way things
used to be is shocking like oh how could
we but I don't know I'm curious your
thoughts what do you think I mean the
problem really with the lot of these
shootings what Democrats focus on gun
control before they even know the facts
like the kid could have been cutting
animals up in his backyard threatening
to kill people rape people but they
don't look into any of the failures
before or prior you know you need to see
what happened before to prevent things
from happening in the future so
Democrats when they focus just on gun
control it it doesn't solve a thing but
that's one thing I could say really
would happen in Florida under it was
governor Scott at the time he formed the
the Marjory Stoneman safety commission
and I was on it and some friends and uh
other fathers that had kids killed and
deputies and sheriffs and lawyers and
they dissected everything that happened
in Parkland and they made changes in the
whole state and Ron DeSantis who I'm
friends with he actually he put He
removed the sheriff he was unbelievable
the guy he removed that failed Sheriff
the first month in office Ron came down
I got a call from him he goes Andy we're
going to remove that sheriff uh and I go
what how are you going to do that he
goes well I'm just going to remove them
I'll be in Tallahassee I go no Governor
you need to come down to Broward go
right in his office and you You Yank
that guy right out of right it was so
great he came flew down the Broward he
had emergency landing on the way down
he's always like hours we're waiting
like everyone's waiting at the Sheriff's
Office and he came down and he removed
the sheriff within the first month that
was like national news that he got rid
of him you know he was the guy that was
on CNN's talking about his amazing
leadership wow he's actually so and he
ran again Broward is such a cesspool so
he actually ran again for office and
almost won that's how bad Broward how
blue and evil Broward county is what do
you think about the uh these kids who
got really famous from uh what happened
in Parkland they started becoming uh I
think for the most part the media props
up this bunch of this group of young
people who are very much gun control
activists yeah but then you had uh Kyle
uh Kashif I'm probably pronouncing your
name wrong Kyle who is more Pro 2A I'm
curious your thoughts on you know how
the media handled it well like I said
they focused on just the gun control and
they didn't accomplish anything but
registered Democrats that's all those
kids accomplished when it came time for
running School Board Races they were
nowhere to be seen when it came time to
get rid of Sheriff nowhere to be seen
getting bills passed Common Sense bills
for school safety there were nowhere to
be seen but me and other couple of
parents and my family my sons we were at
it like non-stop to hold people
accountable
uh Ron I call him Ron I should people
don't know him but go by Governor
DeSantis actually after we removed him
he put a grand jury investigation into
the Broward County school board and just
recently within the last six months four
school board members were removed wow
and the superintendent was arrested so
there's been like what you really want
to make a difference and you go for
accountability you could make a
difference yeah Ron really got involved
on the local level especially when it
came to Local School Board elections and
a lot of people are saying that he did a
really good job how would you rank his
kind of response to everything that
happened in Parkland he did unbelievable
for my family and myself for
accountability you know getting the the
superintendent arrested on felony
charges you know Broward is so bad that
so the superintendent gets arrested
right on felony perjury charges through
the grand jury wouldn't you know that
same year they had that in Broward they
had that superintendent speak at the
school when my daughter was murdered at
graduation that's how bad these these
people are in Broward so he got that
done four school board members he
cleaned house and the deputy was
arrested and and the sheriff was removed
and he just did like where could that
ever happen where I could tell you that
I met him and he told me he was going to
hold these people accountable and and we
did we removed them all they got
arrested they were on charges the city
uh the school board lawyer was arrested
so the media doesn't tell the rest of
the country what really happened they
don't want to focus they're on to the
next mass shooting and they're going to
blame that Black Rifle and then they'll
move on to the next one that's where
they they get all their attention you
know we we on this show we talk about a
lot of the problems that are going we
open up the show with discussing you
know FBI interference and elections and
stuff and it very much feels like we're
constantly pushing this Boulder uphill
endlessly pushing back against this
but for your story and what we've seen
with with similar stories it's not just
pushing a boulder uphill it's like being
on fire at the same time where
something's so devastating so
destructive to your life this problem
that you've not only experienced the
pain you've experienced but you see the
solutions you want the solutions I can't
imagine what it must be like to have
people
working against you these political
forces that we complain about I couldn't
imagine being in your situation well the
worst one of the worst well my daughter
getting murdered that tops everything
but that day my daughter got murdered I
had a trump 2020 shirt on
and some report I was waiting at the
hospital praying that my daughter was
alive takes a picture of my trump shirt
and the hate that I got even what my
daughter like the people were blaming me
for my daughter getting killed on social
media because I had a trump 2020 shirt
on
so
you know
there's a lot of things that I've been
working on uh to try and prevent these
shootings
and working with law enforcement one
thing I'd like to tell you guys that one
of the biggest problems that Society
doesn't realize because you talk about
Mental Health
it's such a failed system uh the mental
health treatment in this country and
what happens to these people that are
mentally ill and I know this factually
because my wife is an ER physician so
she constantly sees mentally ill people
coming into the hospital what happens
with these mentally ill people is
the police pick them up they threaten to
shoot the neighbor they they run a dog
over they kill a cat or they they
they're threatening to rape people the
police just use the hospital as dumping
grounds uh it doesn't get put on their
background whether they threaten to kill
10 people blow up a building they go
right through the system they drop them
off at the hospital they're out in 24
hours with no background so they can
make Democrats can make all the laws
they want you know for backgrounds and
so you can't buy a rifle but if someone
who's mentally ill or criminal doesn't
get a background all the gun laws in the
in the country are never going to
prevent it yeah and it's not just that I
I think it's also fair to say that a lot
of these people just get thrown pills
specifically ssris I don't know if you
heard that conversation or have any kind
of understanding of it from a lot of
these kind of sickos who just get thrown
these pills that mess up their brain
chemistry
um do you have any knowledge of that and
was that related to Parkland as well uh
he was on those type of medications but
there's so many kids that are on it that
don't commit these crimes like there's
kids that play violent video games you
know and don't go out and kill people so
there's I I've heard of that and I and
the one that uh my daughter's murderer
was on those types of medications
yeah it was like ssris do you know the
name of the name of them I forget okay
yeah well a lot of them you know that's
usually one of the common connections
between a lot of these kind of lunatics
um is that you know they go on some of
these medications and it just kind of
makes them go crazy again correlation
does not mean causation a lot of people
like to stretch and just say it's fully
that I think there's a lot of failures
in our society especially when it comes
to fatherless homes especially when it
comes to the medical industry especially
when it comes to law enforcement I mean
there's so many things that we could
address when it comes to the rising
amount of gun violence in this country
um you know which one do you think is
maybe more prominent I think the worst
is the mentally ill not getting the
background you know when they do
something that that deserves it they
just go like there's this what's called
The Baker Act in Florida that if you get
committed and you go through the full
Baker Act where you've put in front of a
judge and a psychiatrist it'll go on
your background but 99.9 percent of that
never happens they just get released and
that's you know the failure there's no
more mental institutions so you take
away if you take you take away 50 of the
mass shootings probably in the country
if the mentally ill that really a
violent you know you have to be careful
there they have to have due process and
and if they had a background on them
they wouldn't be able to purchase do you
think that uh decline in religion plays
a role in a lot of the stuff that and
the fatherless home like you you've said
you know the lat you know families look
with inflation now look what parents
have to do just to stay afloat man even
if there are two parents you know they
work in you know they're working you
know just to be able to afford a dozen
eggs now you know the price of
everything food gas apparent you know
years ago my mom stayed home you know
when I was growing up how many parents
now have that ability where they don't
need a two-parent two parents working
so it is a problem in society
people looking at me like I'm I got some
wisdom I thought you were going to say
something I'm trying to find out what
drug the guy was on I couldn't figure it
out I think a big part of it is really
wasn't focusing on the drugs you know
because they want they wanted the death
penalty you know so they're not gonna
they don't want any outs with any drugs
or any mental illness you know I I asked
about the you know religion but it's not
just about religion it's about a
cohesive cultural structure it's
everything it's all the whole family
unit right I see is struggling and uh
you know I couldn't help but to notice
too because you know Ian's copy of
genderqueer is sitting next to you
you're familiar with that whole
controversy uh not I don't follow it
that much but I know we can't follow it
with the sports and stuff this is men
competing in women's sports and
different bathrooms and genders this
book is in grade schools and I can't
show you what's in it because it's a
violation of Twitter's I'm sorry of
Twitter of YouTube's rules to show the
content that's in that book that's
awesome it's a graphic content that
they're having kids well see and this is
this is a component I just just I don't
want to sure but the governor in Florida
was attacked for just they put this bill
in place I don't you guys must have
heard it what they they wanted to make
it to don't say gay Bill really
education but really it was uh teachers
have no right teaching anything about
sexuality and kindergarten first grade
and second grade and that's all it was
and they attacked the guy like what
parent would want you to sending your
child to school and kindergarten they're
talking about and then they like their
identity yeah and then they lied about
it they said it was the don't say gay
Bill there was nothing in there not
about that at all they just wanted to
attack them exactly and then the
national media and the Democratic Party
All March in lockstep saying anybody who
brings it up is lying about it including
Disney that's right what the hectic why
is the guy even saying anything and then
but what's great is so the governor
DeSantis went at Disney they were
getting all these special tax breaks for
being a Florida Corp and he pulled them
all from them so now they're like paying
like he's doing very Savage a guy is a
Savage interest he's a great guy well so
you know I bring this up because the
stuff we're seeing in schools the
decline uh I should say the rise of
secularism and the decline of religion
all seem to be components in not just
shootings at schools shootings in in
cities a rise in violent crime in all
the major cities but also an
unwillingness from people in the
community to actually try to save each
other
so uh you know talking about having a
Parkland talking about hat with Uvaldi
like I said it's it's kind of like what
we see with communist China these cops
are like you can't go in I'll get sued
and I'm not going to save them because I
don't care about you I don't know who
you are and you don't mean anything to
me well it it depends you know it's a
serious thing you know I get a lot of
calls from parents and emails about
their children in the schools and what's
going on about everything gen their
identity security what they're teaching
in the schools restorative justice
programs and my first answer to them is
because I it's really painful I can't
answer everybody about their kid getting
bullied or want another kid getting
murdered but the quickest response would
be if you could afford it you send your
kid to private school when do you guys
ever hear of the last school shooting
that was at a private school you never
hear about it and if you can't afford
private school you home school or you
move to a district where that's not
going on homeschooling has been
increasing dramatically but I think that
latest project Veritas video came from a
very elite private school where people
are spending about thirty to forty
thousand dollars a kid per year and they
have teachers there that are doing
unspeakable things that if we mentioned
here on this YouTube channel we would
get cut off automatically we can we can
yeah let's put it this way project
Veritas put on an expose where the dean
of students said that they pass around
adult toys and discuss the difference
between lube and spit and just and and
instruct the children on how to insert
these things into their bodies and this
is an elite uh private high school with
14 year olds being uh told this what's
the school name
um I'm gonna have to double Francis or
something Francis park or something like
that Francis W Park well it goes back to
like every Community the parents have
the power to make a change with their
elections and in all starts like you've
mentioned the School Board elections are
more important than who's living in the
white house but you look at what's
happening this it's all tied together
when we see the economy start imploding
these parents don't have time to go to
these meetings they got to work two jobs
and they got to work two jobs each so
now you don't got parents who can be at
home with their kids they this is
breaking up the family then they're
using the schools as daycare centers
also bad for the family then you get
teachers who are trying to subvert the
parents guidance like what we saw in
Florida resulting in Ron DeSantis you
know pushing us on along with
Republicans the parental rights and
education
you actually see now the craziest thing
out of Chicago with this private school
forty thousand dollars a year
this guy on camera is saying it's really
cool that he gets to do this and when
Veritas exposed them for showing
children young young kids these these
adult objects at describing their use
and insertion the school defended the
dean the school insulted
defamed Veritas in my opinion said that
they were malicious
actively defending the depraved behavior
when that's the power of the parents you
know who would send their child to a
school like that take your kid out of
that school and make them go bankrupt
it's only because of project Veritas
that they might know because they're
working the economy is in the gutter
what are you supposed to do you go to
work and you pray that your kids are and
both parents are working right so the
family is being gutted and destroyed and
it's affecting like you said crime
shootings uh kids taking drugs fentanyl
it's all it floats it starts at the
bottom you know plus social media uh
influencing the minds of children early
on parents just giving a phone to to
children and then they're in the hands
of social media that is essentially
creating a a a kind of thought control
where their curated particular content
that they want them to see you add that
with a horrible diet you add that with
people not having you know the right gut
the right brain working uh correctly
it's a recipe for a disaster and I think
we're going to be seeing a lot more
violent events especially with the
increase in poverty especially with the
increase of fatherless homes I think
it's almost guaranteed that there's
going to be a lot more shootings a lot
more violent acts with children coming
our way because there's all their all
the ingredients are there and there's
nothing taking away from this larger uh
problem that I don't I think is sadly
unavoidable right I hear all this and
I'm saying to myself how fortunate it
was to grow up in the 80s yeah and party
like a rock star my biggest worry was
like where was the party that week and
where we're gonna go get a cold keg of
Budweiser thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time